most of the new arrivals are repeat
offenders and know how to survive behind
bars hey guys you're gonna have to give
you a urine test so just kind of hold on
Boggs has no criminal history he landed
in prison in part because he's a social
outcast six zero zero six four six five
bugs committed his crime threatening a
stranger with a knife after being fired
from his job you go pass the black get
up in here and then just with few
friends to turn to he says he just
snapped I attacked somebody at the mall
uh anything your mom five years I have
somewhat antisocial tendencies I tend to
keep to myself a lot and that helps keep
all the anger and I don't unload on a
lot of people so it was more of ice
self-isolation that helped cause it but
to survive among these young inmates
Boggs must make alliances he befriends
nineteen year old Ben Byford serving his
second stint at Fort Dodge for a string
of burglaries
Boggs needs bifur to show him the ropes
his River program in the middle is the
library in the school yeah Randall
knocking on behind those windows and
across the yard other inmates size them
up the true test will be inside their
new home is Emmet unit
150 inmates live eat and sleep here
some entered prison as young men now
they're hardened veterans waiting to
gang up on anyone who appears weak
Boggs arrives in the unit during Chow
what's up Stan what's up man that's my
dude right there straight got a really
good words
in line he mistakes taunting for
friendliness um I'm from Cedar Falls
yeah
what they owe no career please it was
brutal
Brittany yeah you heard freely tonight
think so no Brittany Brittany is slang
for coward